Bitte schön. Alles klar.
Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Salih Tasch. Ich bin heute Stationarzt.
Dann würde ich gerne mit Ihnen eine Annamnesie-Gespräch durchführen.
Ist das klar für Sie?
Ja, wir sehen auch dann.
Genau. Ich würde gerne zunächst ein paar Fragen bis zu Ihrer persönlichen Darstellung stellen.
Dann komme ich gleich zu Ihrem aktuellen Beschwerden.
Okay.
Wie heißen Sie Witze?
Ich heiße Sebastian Beck.
Sebastian Beck. Können Sie Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen stabilen?
Sebastian schreibt sich S-E-B-A-S-T-I-A-N.
Genau.
Und Beck schreibt sich B-E-C-K.
Beck.
Ja, genau. Wie alt sind Sie Witze?
22.
Genau, sind Sie gewohnt?
Am 17. Mai 2001.
Genau.
Wie schwer und groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,84 m groß.
84.
Und wiege 76 kg?
76 kg.
Ja.
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen? Was fühlt es dir zu heute?
Ja, in den letzten 5 Tagen habe ich eine zunehmende Schwäche.
Ich bin müde, kann nicht richtig schlafen.
Ich habe Fieber bis 39° gemessen.
Ich habe starke Schwitzen.
Ich habe Schluckstörungen.
Das Schlucken fällt mir etwas schwer.
Das geht mir nicht gut.
Sind alle beschwerden gleichzeitig angefangen?
Oder wie ist passiert?
Ja, die haben so ziemlich gleichzeitig angefangen.
Ich fühlte mich müde.
Ich habe die Fieber gemessen.
Ich war sehr erschrocken, dass das 39° war.
Die Fieber, die sich schon gemessen haben,
waren dauerhaft?
Ich habe eigentlich die letzten 5 Tage immer Fieber gehabt.
Was haben Sie gemacht dagegen?
Medikamente eingenommen?
Ich habe gestern mal eine Paracetamol genommen.
Wie stark ist das?
Das Fieber ist nur ganz wenig runtergegangen.
Vielleicht um ein halbes Grad.
Das hat nicht viel geholfen.
Wie war die Dosierung der Medikamente?
Paracetamol für erwachsene Stande.
Ein Jahr und 1000.
Die Leidens- und Abgesteigenheit seit 5 Tagen.
Bühne schlappt seit 5 Tagen.
Sind Sie wegen dieser Beschwerden bei einem als gewesen schon?
Bis jetzt noch nicht.
Haben Sie auch Schmerzen?
Bauchschmerzen, Kopfschmerzen?
Nein, nur ein bisschen Halsschmerzen.
Wenn ich etwas schlucken möchte, dann tut das etwas weh im Hals.
Hals ist auch etwas geschwollen, außen rum.
Aber ich weiß es nicht genau.
Das müssen Sie vielleicht noch mal bei der Untersuchung feststellen.
Das mache ich gerne.
Die Schwellung des Haars, in der Halbzentze, 5 Zageln?
Ja, auch in den letzten 5 Tagen ist das gekommen.
Ich habe schon bemerkt, dass es eine Auslösung ist.
Ich kann mir das nicht so berüchtig erklären.
Ich hatte vor 14 Tagen eine Zahnoperation.
Da musste ein entzündeter Zahn entfernt werden.
Vor zwei Wochen war das.
Ich war danach noch zweimal zur Kontrolle bei dem Arzt.
Der Arzt sagte, soweit ist er zufrieden.
Die Wunde verheilt ganz gut.
Das war vor zwei Wochen.
Haben Sie nach der Operation Medikamenten?
Sie würden es reingenommen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Obwohl nachher mir gesagt wurde,
dass ich das hätte nehmen müssen.
Vor einem knappen Jahr hatte ich eine Herzoperation.
Da wurde mir letztendlich gesagt,
dass ich mindestens ein Jahr danach bei solchen Eingriffen,
wie beim Zahnarzt oder beim Halsnasenrohrenarzt
oder beim Urulogen, eine Antibiotikum bräuchte.
Das hat leider nichts stattgefunden.
Können Sie noch mal erklären,
ich habe etwas verpasst auswährend.
Was hat der Zahnarzt gesagt?
Zahnarzt hat nur kontrolliert nach der 2 Tage nach der Operation.
Dann noch mal 2 Tage später hat er die Wunde angeschaut.
Damit war der Zahnarzt zufrieden.
Okay.
Haben Sie noch etwas erzählt,
dass etwas vom Hals war?
Nein, ich bin vor einem Jahr am Herz operiert worden.
Vor einem Jahr?
Ja, ich habe es auch gesagt.
Ich habe es gesagt,
ich müsste für ein Jahr lang ein Antibiotikum bekommen
bei Operationen oder Zahnarzt.
Das hat aber nichts stattgefunden.
Haben Sie selbst nicht eingenommen?
Nein, ich habe nicht daran gedacht.
Warum wurde das operiert?
Was genau, die Diagnose?
Im Herzen.
Da war ein Loch in der Herzscheidewand.
Dieses Loch, ich bekam,
wenn ich Sport machte und ich mache regelmäßig Sport,
dann bekam ich schlechter Luft und ich fühlte mich auch nicht fit.
Und dann wurde ich unter der Hand.
Dann wurde dieses Loch festgestellt.
Das wurde dann über eine Katheteruntersuchung
wie eine Art Schirm verschlossen.
Danach ging es mir jetzt auch viel besser.
Ich konnte besser Sport treiben.
Vor einem Jahr?
Vor elf Monaten.
Ich sollte jetzt in einem Monat wieder zum Kardiologen
zur Kontrolle.
Um das Ergebnis zu überprüfen, aber den Termin habe ich.
Jetzt habe ich eben Fieber und jetzt bin ich hier bei Ihnen.
Verspüren Sie Herzrasen?
Der Puls ist etwas schneller, aber ich glaube, das ist das Fieber.
Ich glaube, das ist das Fieber.
Dass ich da vielleicht etwas schnelleren Puls habe.
Oder Herr Storpan?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Leidien sind es auch,
unser anderen konischer Erkrankung?
Ja, ich habe Asthma.
Seit circa zehn Jahren, gut zehn Jahren habe ich Asthma.
Da wurde mir gesagt,
ich habe Asthma.
Da wurde mir gesagt, das ist allergisches Asthma
auf Hausstaub und auf Getreidepollen.
Da nehme ich auch zwei Medikamente.
Damit geht das eigentlich ganz gut.
Du hast nehmen Sie etwas genau?
Einmal Salbutamolspray.
Also zwei bis dreimal am Tag,
je nachdem, wie es mir geht.
Ich habe noch Buddisonit.
Einmal am Tag.
Gerade im Herbst und Winter.
Oder wenn ich die Symptome habe mit Getreide,
dann nehme ich es auch zweimal am Tag.
Bekommen Sie Asthma-Anfall?
In den letzten Monaten gar nichts mehr.
Das ist eigentlich inzwischen ganz gut eingestellt.
Können wir sagen, unser Grundsäure?
Ja, ich bin da auch regelmäßig einmal im Jahr beim Lungenfacharzt.
Einmal im Jahr beim Hausarzt.
Der macht Lungenfunktionsmessung und so weiter.
Ich bin bisher ganz zufrieden.
Gibt es noch die Erkrankungen,
unter denen Sie leiden?
Ich habe noch, da sagen die Leute,
das ist eine Verbindung.
Ich habe auch noch Neurodentrum.
Besonders im Winter.
Und dann muss ich Hautpflegesalbe nehmen.
Und wenn es mal ganz schlimm wird,
dann muss ich auch mal eine Salbe mit Cortison nehmen.
Aber das ist eher selten der Fall.
Im Winter besonders sind Sie davon betroffen.
Wenn die Luft trocken ist,
im Winter, in der Heizungsluft, dann ist das viel schlimmer.
Das ist eine sehr große Erkrankung.
Erinnern Sie daran, oder wissen Sie schon ganz genau,
ob die Diagnose über Ihr Herzproblem war?
Was ist die Diagnose?
Als Sie uns der Fall haben, oder etwas?
Nein, es sei eine kleine Öffnung,
die eigentlich ein Säugel,
ein Säugel, ein Säugel, ein Säugel,
ein Säugling noch hat, heißt es,
und die sich dann nach der Geburt verschließt.
Das versteh ich, Dcus.
Bei manchen Menschen verschließt sich das nicht.
Das macht doch dann keine Probleme.
Aber bei manchen eben doch und das war aber mir der Fall.
Ja, genau.
Wurden Sie schon
operiert, außer das?
Ja, ich hatte als Kind, da war ich so ungefähr zehn Jahre alt, hatte ich einen Leistenbruch auf der rechten Seite und das wurde operiert und das war alles in Ordnung.
Ja, habe ich schon mal bemerkt, dass sie abgenommen haben in letzter Zeit?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht in den letzten Jahren immer gehalten.
Stuhlfrost, Leidensaufe.
Ja, so ein bisschen Schüttelfrost hatte ich heute Nacht und auch starkes Schlitzen.
Auch Beschieblichkeiten beim Wasserlassen, beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, Wasserlassen musste ich jetzt nicht so viel. Ich glaube, ich habe viele Flüssigkeit verloren durch das Schlitzen.
Ich habe jetzt die Urin sehr dunkel, aber ich habe versucht immer etwas zu trinken, aber ich habe auch keinen Appetit.
Jetzt, seitdem ich viele habe, Stuhlgang war normal.
Darf ich fragen, ob ihr Eltern im Leben sind noch?
Ja, wir haben meine Eltern leben.
Der Vater hat auch Asthma, der ist 52 Jahre alt.
Die Mutter ist auch 52 Jahre alt, die hat bei den drei Jahren einen Brustkrebs festgestellt.
Dann ist sie operiert worden und hat noch Chemotherapie bekommen und auch eine Bestrahlung.
Aber im Augenblick sind die Ergebnisse zufriedenstellend.
Ja, Gott sei Dank.
Ich habe noch einen Bruder, der 18 Jahre alt, der hat auch Asthma.
Genau, das ist eine Chemotherapie.
Eine Schwester, die ist 20 Jahre alt, die hat eine vergrößerte Schilddrüse und eine leichte Unterfunktion.
Aber sonst geht es sehr gut.
Nimmt sie etwas mit ein Medikament?
Ich glaube, sie nimmt ein Medikament ein.
Aber ich wohne ja nicht mehr zu Hause, meine Schwester auch nicht mehr.
Sie lebt auch in einer anderen Stadt, ich weiß jetzt nicht, welches Medikament sie nimmt.
Können Sie?
Nein, habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Ja, lass es doch mal.
Trinkst du Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke Alkohol, so ein bis zwei Mal in der Woche.
Vielleicht so ein bis zwei Flaschen Bier, aber das ist nicht regelmäßig.
Geh länger, ich würde sagen.
Ein, zwei Flasche Bier.
Darf ich fragen, ob Sie bisher Kontakt zu Drogen gehabt haben?
Ich nicht.
Studieren Sie oder was machen Sie?
Studiere Geschichte und Englisch.
Mit welchem Semester sind Sie?
Ich bin im Sechsten.
Sind Sie damit zufrieden?
Ja, es ist anstrengend, aber es macht mir Spaß.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, ich lebe in einer Wohngemeinschaft mit vier anderen Studenten.
Darf ich fragen, ob Sie Partner haben?
Ja, ich habe erfahren, sie lebt aber nicht dort in der Wohngemeinschaft.
Leiden Sie unseres Verträglichen gegen Lebensmittel oder Medikamente?
Ich habe nur oben wegen dem Asthma Getreidepollen in der Saison und Hausstaub.
Das ist mein Problem.
Wie aussetzt, ist das ganz genau?
Wenn ich keine Medikamente nehmen würde, würde ich verstärkt Luftnot haben und Asthma.
Ist das Asthma-Syptomen?
Sind Sie vollständig?
Ja, ich war vor einigen Monaten in Thailand.
Ich war vorher beim Hausarzt und habe den Impfpass angeschaut und sagte, das wäre alles ausreichend.
Vor einigen Wochen?
Vor vier Monaten.
Ich würde eine kleine Zusammenfassung machen.
Leiden Sie uns seit den letzten fünf Tagen und abgeschleidenheit, Fieber und etwas aufschwitzen.
Ich habe auch gemerkt, dass Sie angeschwitzt sind.
Etwas, ja.
Ich gebe es nur beschwerden.
Was ist die Schlappheit und Müdigkeit?
Was kann das sein, dass ich fünf Tage lang so hohes Fieber habe?
Die Schwellung sind die beiden Seiten oder die einen Seiten?
Ich habe den Eindruck, dass es so geschwollen ist.
Ich habe etwas Kartes getrunken.
Ich habe am Ende mit meinem Gespräch getrunken.
Ich würde Sie körperlich untersuchen und Blut abnehmen.
Sie können mit verschiedenen Sachen zusammen hängen.
Ich habe ein Malgeländesündung getrunken.
Es ist etwas schwerer und ernsthaft.
Ich muss erst Sie körperlich untersuchen und Blut abnehmen.
Sie haben einige Minuten Zeit.
Ich habe noch ein paar Minuten Zeit.
Ich habe nicht mehr gebrochen.
Ich habe etwas Schwindelich.
Ich habe kein Apetit.
Ich habe keine Hunger.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Klar.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Fieber genau beschreiben?
Ich habe jetzt zweimal am Tag gemessen.
Das ist morgens 38,5 Grad.
Aber es geht meistens am Nachmittag und Abend bis 39 Grad.
Einige Beschwerden sind aufgetreten.
Ich kann mich nicht daran erinnern, dass ich so etwas schon mal hatte.
Ich hatte als Kind mal eine Grippe.
Aber das war höchstens zwei Tage das Fieber.
Ich verstehe.
Ich kann nicht genau verstehen.
Welche Antibiotikum haben Sie eingenommen?
Ich habe kein Antibiotikum eingenommen.
Das ist vergessen worden.
Im Nachherein hätte ich doch das nehmen müssen.
Ich habe ein Merkblatt mitbekommen.
Ich habe das mit dem zentrum.
Ich muss bei solchen Eingriffen ein Antibiotikum nehmen.
Sie haben vergessen bei der Zahnarzt.
Ich habe es vergessen.
Der Zahnarzt wusste nicht, dass ich das vergessen habe.
Das war nicht gut.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Gibt es in Ihrer Umgebung jemanden, der gleich oder einiger Beschwerder hat?
Soweit ich weiß, gibt es niemanden.
Auch in meiner Wohngemeinschaft nicht.
Ich kenne niemanden, der ähnliche Akute beschwerden hat.
Haben Sie sich selbst Covid-19-Tests durchgeführt?
Was für ein Test? Ein Covid?
Covid-19, ja.
Nein, habe ich nicht gemacht.
Ich habe es mit mir erst gesagt, ich werde es starten.
Von mir aus können wir anfangen.
Sali?
Ja, ich muss auch.
Ja, es ist so.
Probieren Sie es.
Ich bin Per medida.
Ok.
Guten Abend Herr Orbart.
Guten Abend.
Ich habe vor kurzem einen jungen Patient gesehen.
Ja.
Dann würde ich Ihnen vorstellen.
Gerne.
Herr Beck ist ein 22-Jähriger, 1,84 m, großer und 76 kg schwerer Patient, der sich heute
bei uns wegen seit letzten 5 Tagen bestehende progradierende Halsschmerzen vorgestellt hat.
Des Weiteren klagt, berichtet er über Feber und Schwitzen, dysphagie und Abschlagenheit.
Okay.
Also Herr Beck ist ein 22-jähriger Student, der sich heute bei uns vorgesteilt hat.
Er ist 1,84 m groß, 76 kg schwer.
Ja, genau.
Beck klagt seit 5 Tagen über Leistungsknick, Müdigkeit, Fatigue, über febrile Temperaturen
bis 39 Grad und dysphagie.
Gut.
Genau.
Und er fügt hinzu, dass seine Fass angeschoben sei.
Okay.
Genau.
Er berichtet über eine diffuse Schwellung im Halsbereich.
Mir wissen wir noch nicht.
Ja, genau.
Außerdem die Frage nach Vertigo, nause und heißt Palpitation und Tahibneu, auch Tahikadi.
Nein, Tahikadi gibt es.
Ja, Tahikadi gibt es.
Tahibneu wurde verändert, aber er hat auch gesagt, dass er Tahikadi gehabt habe.
Oder er berichtet über zumindest einen beschleunigten Puls.
Ja, genau, beschleunigten Puls.
Als Vorerkrankung habe er erwähnt, dass er vor 11 Monaten ungefähr ein atrial septal
defek oder wetschkühles septal defek.
Atrial septal, atrium septal defek.
Er hat nicht genau gesagt, dass er das atrial septal defek ist, aber er hat gemeint, dass
er Schweinlob-Operationen gehabt habe.
Oder viele Menschen haben ja auch ein persistierendes Vorrahmen-Ovale.
Ja, vorrahmende Ovale.
Ja.
Und ein persistierendes Vorrahmen-Ovale gibt es zwar, glaube ich, relativ häufig,
aber keine Symptome.
Ja.
Es sind Patienten, der wurde symptomatisch und bekam deswegen eine Oklusions-Propelle
in Form eines Stirmchens, das Vorrahmen aufgespannt sind.
Das heißt, atrial septum defekt.
Korruptive.
Ja.
Also persistierendes Vorrahmen-Ovale und eine Oklusions-Propelle.
Das war für uns 11 Monate.
Mhm.
Genau.
Aber wichtig ist, dass er nach der Operation nicht gut Antibiotikaterapie
bekommen habe.
Es wurde, es wird standardmäßig für 12 Monate eine Antibiotikaprofilaxe gefordert
oder angeraten bei Eingriffen.
Und was hat der Patient für einen Eingriff bekommen vor zwei Wochen?
Genau.
Er wurde auch beim Zahnarzt einen Eingriff...
Ja.
Er erfolgte eine Zahnextraktion.
Genau.
Zahnherd oder eine beherdeten Zahn.
Leider ohne Antibiotikaprofilaxe.
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Gibt es andere chronische Erkrankungen bei den Patienten?
Ja, genau.
Er leide auch unter Asthma seit zehn Jahren.
Warum?
Dagegen nehmen wir seine Bezirke.
Seit zehn Jahren besteht ein wohl allergisches Asthma-Branchale
auf Hausstaub und Getreide.
Ja, genau.
Genau, gegen Polen und Getreide und Hausstaub.
Gut.
Genau.
Könnt ihr wiederholen, Herr Haiko?
Ja.
Er besteht...
Seit zehn Jahren besteht ein Asthma-Branchale,
oder man kann auch sagen ein allergisches Asthma-Branchale
bei bekannten Hausstaub und Getreide-Unverträglichkeit oder Allergie.
Das ist bestimmt ja der Begriff der Hausstauballergie.
Viele Menschen hier zu Tade, das ist ein Hausstaub.
Bekommt, nimmt der Patient regelmäßig Medikamente?
Genau.
Salbzammol, Spre, auch Boudiconit.
Boudiconit, ja.
Boudiconit, einmal täglich.
Ja, ist das Asthma darunter gut kontrolliert?
Genau, er meinte, dass die Krankheit ums Kontrolle ist.
Ja.
Gibt es noch andere Operationen bei dem
Leistenhärmung?
Ja, in den letzten zehn Jahren eine Herrniotomy bei
Herrnia Inguinalis Rechts.
Ja, genau.
Also hat er auch gemeint, dass er unser Anära-dermatitis
hat gesagt, dass im Winter die Symptomen verstärken sein.
Der Patient leidet auch seit Jahren an einer Neurodermitis mit
einer Verschlechterung im Winterhalt.
Ja, genau.
Gut.
Dagegen nehmen er bei Bedarf Cortisonsalve und Hautsalve.
Was bedeutet mit Cortisonsalve?
Im Kunst milde Hautpflegesalve macht er regelmäßig Hautpflege
mit Salven und bei, jetzt sagen wir das Begriff, Ex-Azervation,
eine Cortisonhaltige Salve, die er ihr jetzt nicht genau benennen
konnte, welches Präparat.
Sie haben gesagt Salve mit Cortison.
Ja, man kann sagen auch Cortisonhaltige Salve.
Okay.
Manchmal sind es ja auch Mischsalven, die in der Apotheke hergestellt
werden.
Man hat einen Anteil Cortison drin und ein anderer Anteil.
Gibt es sonstige Auffälligkeiten in der jüngeren Vorgeschichte des
Patienten?
Familie der Anämenese.
Genau.
Der Patient ist der Patient im Ausland gewesen, in den letzten
Jahren.
Ja, genau.
Er war in Thailand vor vier Monaten.
Aber er meinte, bevor er in Thailand gegangen ist, hat er bei seinem
Hausarzt eine Impfberatung oder Impf.
Genau.
Der Impfstatus vor der Reise war der Impfstatus laut Hausarzt in
Ordnung.
Ja, genau.
Der Patient in Thailand in einem Malaria-Gebiet.
Aber vor vier Monaten, Herr Heiko.
Eine Malaria kann bis zu einem Jahr nach Rückkehr ausbrechen.
Ja.
Eine wichtige Frage, eine wichtige Frage, die Sie dem Patient
stellen müssen.
Die nächste Frage wäre, hat der Patient eine Malaria-Prophylaxe
betrieben?
Nein.
Der Patient hat keine Malaria-Prophylaxe betrieben, weil ihm
gesagt wurde, dass die Jahreszeit nicht malariatypisch ist.
Und er war auch nicht in einem ganz gefährlichen Malaria-Gebiet.
Aber er weiß es nicht genau.
Aber eine Malaria-Prophylaxe wurde nicht betrieben?
Es hätte auch fragen können, vieler, dass er vom einen
Mücke gestochen ist.
Das weiß man ja nicht immer.
Man merkt das nicht immer.
Und die Frage sollte man stellen.
In Thailand irgendwelche Erkrankungen gehabt, haben Sie,
waren Sie Malaria-Gebiet, haben Sie eine Malaria-Prophylaxe
betrieben und waren Sie auch ausreichend?
Ja.
Sie entnehmen das leider nur zur Hälfte oder so etwas?
Gut.
Die Frage gehört dazu.
In der Familienanamnese ist erwähnungswert,
dass ihr Mutter unser Brutkrebs hat.
Wie ist das mit der Szenom?
Mamakatsinom.
Oder wegen des Mamakatsinoms, operiert wurde.
Vor drei Jahren wurde Mutter an einem rechtseitigen
Mamakatsinom operiert.
Er bekommt jetzt Straloptherapie.
Eine Radiation.
Radiation.
Sein Vater leidet auch an Asma.
Ja.
Auch sein Bruder leidet auch an Asma.
Mhm.
Genau.
Seine Geschwister hat...
Meine Schwester.
Meine Schwester hat...
Pypothröse.
Seine Schwester hat wohl eine hypothyriote Stroma.
Die leidet unter der Schilddrösen Vergrößerung.
Ja.
Mit hypothyriose.
Gut.
Okay.
Die Begede tipa an Amnesie ist unauffällig bis auf Inappatents,
die leitet seit letzten fünf Tagen auch Stuhlfrost, Pilexie,
aber die Fragen nach Wasserlass und Stuhlgang gibt es keine
Auffälligkeiten.
Ja.
Gut.
Und es besteht eine ausgeprägte Hyperheterosiz.
Hyperheterosiz.
Gut.
Ich habe drei Verdachtstiatmosen.
Es könnte sein, erst mal ein Tonzylitis.
Okay.
Nein, aber nicht ganz...
Das ließe sich ja durch eine, sagen wir mal,
Inspektion in die Mundhöhle relativ schnell erklären,
wie der Rachen innen drin aussieht.
Ja, okay.
Und nach der Operation könnte er jetzt absetzen,
auftreten, weil er keine richtigen Medikamente
an die Bibliothekotherapie bekommen hat,
nach der Operation.
Okay.
Und was kommt noch,
differentialdiagnostisch im Betracht?
Er war in Thailand, viel hat auch.
Ja.
Malaria sein, ja, genau.
Ich sage, die Malaria, wo reisemedizinische Fortbildung
gemacht, und da wurde extra darauf hingewiesen,
es gibt Fälle, wo die Leute erst ein Jahr nach Rückkehr
Malaria-Symptome entwickelt haben.
Hab ich nie für möglich gehalten,
aber diese Fälle gibt es.
Und ich bin keine Ideologie.
Was gibt noch andere Diagose, die mir sehr wichtig ist?
Ja.
Siehst du?
Uns hat der Patient unterlassen.
Was wurde weder von ihm noch vom Zahnarzt gemacht?
Ja.
Das fest mir ist der gerade nicht.
Es wurde ja seitens der Herzklinik,
wo der Patient diesen Eingriff hatte mit der
Proklusion, wurde ja für ein Jahr eine
endokaditis Profilaxe empfohlen.
Ja, genau.
Und malerweise soll es ja.
Ja.
Und was könnte bei den Patienten vorliegen?
Endokaditis, ja, genau.
Das muss man zumindest.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, ja, genau.
Das muss man auf alle Fälle in Erwägung ziehen.
Und ich sage mal, die beiden gravierenden Diagnosen
bei den Patienten wäre der Verdacht auf endokaditis
oder der Verdacht auf malaria.
Ja.
Das sind zwei vital bedrohliche Krankheitsbilder.
Dagegen wäre jetzt eine tonsilitis oder
ein Abscess noch vergleichsweise langenmal harmlos.
Es käme auch noch in Betracht bei den Patienten
eine Mononukleose.
Ja, ja.
Der Patient ist 22 Jahre alt.
Er hat Kontakte und eine Mononukleose.
Er kann durchaus so hohe Temperaturen machen
und auch eine Angina emitieren.
Das kann zu diffusen Schwellungen führen.
Vielleicht hat der Patient auch noch eine geschwollene Milz.
Das weiß er aber nicht genau.
Das würde die Untersuchung ergeben.
Also ich würde die erste Verdachtdiagnose
auf alle Fälle.
Endokaditis, ja.
Ja, genau.
Bei mangelhafter Profilaxe.
Die nächste Stufe wäre schnell zu objektivieren
durch einen dicken Tropfen im Labor.
Verdacht auf malaria.
Das lässt sich schnell ausschließen.
Die anderen Diagnosen wie eine Endokaditis
ist sicherlich umfangreicher.
Und das andere wäre eine Mononukleose
beziehungsweise ein Abscess.
Aber der Zahnarzt hat zweimal kontrolliert
und gesagt, der Lokalefund ist gut.
Das war so erstmal das.
Ja, genau.
Das war etwas gemein von mir.
Aber es ist einfach ein unklares Fieber.
Da sollten Sie auch...
haben Sie nachgefragt mit dem Herz.
Was wurde denn da gemacht?
Das wurde vergessen mit dem Algebra.
Was haben Sie mit dem Algebra mit dem Altybiotikum gegessen?
Bei der Reise an einem Nese
waren Sie etwas nicht genau gefragt.
Da hätte ich mir gewünscht,
dass Sie gefragt haben, Thailand.
Waren Sie im Malaria-Gebiet?
Haben Sie, weil eine Impfung da Ihnen nichts nützt im Augenblick,
zumindest bei Erwachsenen nicht?
Waren Sie eine Malaria-Profilaxe betrieben?
Dann muss man schon zumindest hellhörig werden,
Zustand vor vier Monaten in einer potenziellen Malaria-Gegen gewesen,
auf alle Fälle auf Malaria untersuchen.
Ja, gut.
Ich habe Sie zwischendurch etwas verwirrt,
weil ich einfach zwischendurch etwas gesagt habe.
Aber Sie haben versucht,
die Anamese systematisch aufzubauen
und zu heben.
Versuchen Sie weiterhin.
Da hat der einleitende Arzt beim Oberarzt war sehr lang.
Herr Beck ist das und das,
der sich dann bei uns, das war ein ganz langer Satz,
wo Sie dann am Ende vielleicht gar nicht mehr genau wissen,
was hatte ich jetzt so richtig alles gesagt.
Machen Sie lieber vorher mal einen Punkt
und beginnen Sie einen neuen Satz.
Das ist besser für Sie, für die Übersicht.
Wir versuchen natürlich die Fachbegriffe
zu erinnern, wenn jemand sagt, ich habe 39 Grad Fieber,
dann sollten Sie sagen, es bestehen bei den Patienten
seit fünf Tagen, Februar, Temperaturen bis 39.
Und dann habe ich jetzt, war jetzt nicht so gemein,
ich habe nicht gefragt, wo hat der Patient das denn gemessen.
Unter der Achselhöhle,
Rektal oder Oral.
Das würde ich auch kurz fragen, Herr Beck,
wo haben Sie das Fieber gemessen?
Das wäre noch so, dass Sie das noch dazu bringen.
Und die anderen Dinge,
an denen können Schildrüssen vergrößern,
Stromer, die leisten Herr Nea,
Herr Nea, Ingrinalis mit Herrn Jotomi.
Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,
sehr wichtiges mit Herrn Jotomi.
Dass Sie das sich möglichst dann hinter diese Begriffe schreiben.
Jeder hat so seine eigene Technik.
Und dann denke ich,
ist das dann eine vernünftige Vorbereitung für den Patient.
Ja, danke.